hey everyone welcome to Sweetwater
secrets I'm Liana Galera
joined right now by the one and only
Chad Michael Murray who you may have
mixed feelings about as Edgar ever never
just a little Chad thank you so much for
being on Sweetwater we really appreciate
it thank you and I've got to say welcome
to the Riverdale family how has it been
so far absolutely incredible absolutely
incredible I'm loving every minute of it
and you know I would say Edgar means
well he does mean well he does mean well
this is a character that we heard so
much about the entire season but we've
never been introduced to him until this
very end what have they told you about
the character of Edgar when you first
heard about this role I think I'm left
just as much in the dark as maybe you
guys are so very very very little so it
was really more of a psychological
journey for me to discover how I wanted
to create Edgar inside-out right and I
thought to myself alright cult leader
cult leader collier well what is so
fascinating about a cult leader that
we're all so drawn to him right and you
look at the people the people that join
it says a lot about the cult leader but
it also says a lot about the people that
are joining what is it that they're
looking for so it all manifested by what
is it that Edgar has that draws so many
people in and I think he speaks
everyone's love language and he
understands he's able to read so that
was what it was about for me the best
way that I can think to describe Edgar
is he's frustratingly charming
frustratingly charming you can't help
but just fall under his spell and it
seems to be that's what's happening to
more and more of these Riverdale
residents we're seeing Cheryl blossom
now joining the farm what has it been
like for you to have Madeleine be your
first recruit oh my gosh that was
incredible III think sitting down in
those scenes and in the interview scenes
right and having that much power in the
moment with Edgar and Cheryl Cheryl
who's such a large character that I
think it's that's the perfect way to
that's the perfect person to bring into
the farm first in the world right I mean
obviously we already had Alice she was
already there which we knew of
but to have Cheryl come in and to entice
her and to find out what it is that she
needs and to give it to her that's cool
um in this week's episode tomorrow
night's episode we are going to be
seeing that Edgar and Betty have another
sit-down and she's desperately looking
for these answers what can you choose
for the fans out there as to what they
can expect from tomorrow night's episode
Oh Edgar is going to inform Betty why it
is that the farm exists today right what
his main agenda is he's gonna open up
and you know Betty needs to know so I
think he's going to start to unravel
things and start to let some of the
mysteries out we've seen in a sneak-peek
clip that we do get to learn more about
Edgar's backstory a little bit and kind
of how he came to be in the position
that he is did you know that backstory
when you first joined the show I knew a
little I knew a little I don't I didn't
know the depths of what I know now
obviously but what you won't find out
too long but get ready
fasten your seat bug cause it gets crazy
but I will say that the amount that I
knew gave me a good base it's a bill
that drama mm-hmm take me back to that
initial conversation you get the call
saying hey they want you to come on to
Riverdale fun fact you're playing a
parent you're now back on the CW but
you're playing a parent that's tied how
are you feeling I think the first thing
that popped into my head was I believe
Paul Johansen was the same age that I am
now when he started on Tree Hill oh my
god right playing Dan Scott so that was
one of the first things that that kicked
in man but slightly surreal yeah very
cool and that I get to look and and be a
fly on the wall and watch a younger
version of myself go through a very
similar thing right two very different
shows but very similar in that they're
going through something that I had a
very similar experience to 15 years ago
right so I get to watch that as an
outsider and man I wish I was as smart
as they were one when I was at yeah yeah
well and also one of the things that is
both a blessing and a curse is at the
Riverdale stars are now having to deal
with social media which wasn't really
prevalent when Tree Hill was on you guys
really got to keep that privacy in your
lives but at the same time you didn't
get that instant fan reaction do you
wish that there had been social media
when you were on the CW on The WB I mean
I think they're in a much more
interesting position they're really
savvy yeah right they handle social
media and all the aspects of fandom and
stardom incredibly well
all right far better than I ever could
have handled it so for me I would say
it's probably a good thing but at the
same time you do look at you know the
the lost opportunities or the ability to
grow a brand or do whatever it is that
you're doing in the business sense of it
mm-hm
it's it would have been really
fascinating to see the following that
tree who would have had at the time in
the current marketplace it's it's it's
you know it's the power of social media
and it blows my mind you know I tried
for so long to go no no no yeah you did
I did I did I waited to like 2013 you
really did 14 I don't even know but I
waited and I've embraced it I'm still
quite private yeah on on on these things
just because for me it's you know I
don't know I just don't want to get too
involved into immersed in it I got two
kids yeah and work and my wonderful wife
so there's a lot I mean you know
someone's gotta take care of certain
things outside the house you know you
know I gotta I mean I'm not mowing the
lawn recently but if it needed mowing
and I wasn't doing anything but you know
there's a lot to be done so I try to
stay away speaking of the outdoors I
have a question this whole time we've
heard about the farm and I've been
imagining this gorgeous farm filled with
pigs and cows and all these great things
will we ever see a farm we've been
talking about this on Sweetwater for the
longest time
a version oh that sounds like a
flashback to me
mmm version Lissy have any of your new
Riverdale co-stars told you that they
loved you on Tree Hill or on Gilmore
Girls
they've been so incredibly welcoming
day one I got there and you guys have
already seen this but the first episode
Edgar's in the crowd and when we meet
him the entire cast was there that day
slow cat holy cow by the way I've always
always wanted a chance to do that right
how would an epic way to do yeah
and it's sure you can wear white after
Labor Day but it's one of those things
where I got introduced and it was a
whole cast here's Chad Chad whole cast
go it was slightly overwhelming mm-hmm
but they were so genuine and there was a
lot of you know just different things
you know I grew up watching ABC Edie it
was all different things by the way that
they had thrown back to from Cinderella
story to Tree Hill to House of Wax the
different things from different people
and it's it's humbling and you know it's
it's always gratifying to hear it right
but I just I just want to be great in
that moment and serve the show and do
them so I always forget
I always forget what I've done and I'm
always thinking about what I'm doing
until fans remind you and then they say
I loved you on this right and it happens
then it happens you know how we go we
could go to malls all the time I love I
don't know why I have a mall thing I
know right my wife wonders too I think
it's a Buffalo thing I was gonna say
where did you go in the wintertime
there's a lot of snow it gets cold out
so you go to the mall yeah yeah so I
tend to want to go to the mall wherever
we're shooting whatever location I just
want to check it out and I'll go to the
mall and I forget what we do and I'm
like oh why are they why is that guy
giving me the stink-eye what's his
problem
oh I forgot I forgot we're starting to
get in some great fan questions and fan
comments right now Oh CJ Brown wants to
know why is Edgar able to convert Cheryl
of all people and how was he able to do
it huh because she's the most headstrong
character on the show she is and I think
she's the perfect per
to join the farm right - to become a
farming it says a lot about Edgar it
says a lot about his power it says a lot
about the work that he's put in the
years of I don't want to say mental
manipulation or mental gymnastics but it
is it's a gift it's a gift to be able to
read people and give them what they need
I will tell you this much you're going
to find out what it is in particular
that he has that she needs and you'll
find out for everybody let's talk about
the fact that you're letting people who
join the farm see dead people
hmm yeah Cheryl's saying that she can
see her brother Jason oh that's right
yeah Alice is saying that she can see
her her son Charles can you give us can
you shed any light onto this because
this is some sixth sense stuff that we
got going on right now that's right
that's right I mean you know yeah I
guess it's that real-life drinking the
kool-aid thing right I know I actually
was reading what was I reading I read
something on social media where someone
said I'll bet it's the candles that's
the candles in the room and see I think
you could see a photo well I see a photo
there's something in the candle there's
something in the candles that must be
emanating in the air and making them you
know psychedelic drugs I think Edgar
sandalwood the wicks in acid and then
said hey here's a teddy bear and they
think it's their brother you know - no
you're just going to find out there are
so many drugs in riverdale at this point
I wouldn't put it past them sneaks them
through in the candles I don't know
that's what they don't know is nothing
is off-limits
here's my question for you because I
loved one Tree Hill okay and then as an
a and I still do but as the show
progressed ish got bonkers and you know
exactly what I'm talking about
things got off the rails um and I know
that Luke is kind of knocked out of
there towards the end of it probably to
get out of that crazy town when you look
at Tree Hill and you look at Riverdale
which town do you think
is crazier I mean if you're going
straight for crazy you know and when you
look at One Tree Hill one of the things
about that show is it was very specific
and it was a very grounded show right
everybody had that existence riverdale
lives in a very different universe yes
it's a it's a it's an elevated universe
you have some fantasy aspects of it you
have a little bit of everything and you
can get away with anything so the term
jumping the shark doesn't really apply
there in Tree Hill
when Ben's heart hit the floor and a dog
who happened to ingest marijuana was in
the ER and the heart comes in from
outside because that's where it would
come in from and falls on the ground in
front of this hungry dog who stoned and
the dog eats the heart in front of Lucas
I called that jumping to show for you
that was the straw that broke the
camel's back for for Luke that's when
chadwin bayi I remember having that
conversation though I remember having
that conversation I walked into the
office and I said guys I know what we're
doing here remember that show the soup
oh yeah
that's all they want it was on the soup
what wanted that they wanted to be on
that's what it was because I mean it was
almost free publicity right yeah right
you get on there people talk about it I
got to check that out and I think that
that's what it had to be because in no
world was that grounded and I think I
said guys the second at that heart hits
the floor I'm done like I can't figure
out my exactly something quick and I not
be there I even asked him do I have to
be there listen yeah so please come on
man like maybe I'm in the room with
Peyton come on man and I was there but
Riverdale you can get away with anything
that's what's so cool about the universe
you're not stuck in a box yeah right you
have the ability to kind of step outside
the boundaries here and then here and
there and that's for every character
every character has a little darkness on
now I know your kids are young but I was
just saying you're gonna get some cool
dad points because you're on Riverdale
cuz right now it is the hottest show on
TV and I just might be a little young
I know give him a couple years though
because elegant Maddy says add him to
the hot river don't dad's group thank
you thank you Maddy yeah thank you Maddy
I appreciate um
Zakhar fee wants to know is Edgar evil
what is his goal in Riverdale
no no wagers not mm-hmm and and I say
that as Chad the actor but also as
edgert because I have to believe that
Edgar has an agenda and when you come
from a certain place what does make the
best villain is somebody who truly
believes that they're doing what's best
for the greater good more for those that
can't so no I just I can't
when I started I said actors not a
villain and I will always believe
editors not a villain because otherwise
how could you manifest this thing and
create the farm and get such a beautiful
following and be so open and read people
the way that he has yeah I just don't
think I can't yeah you you have to be on
his team and remember this is also me
saying this without really knowing very
much at all before we met Edgar we met
his daughter Evelyn played by the lovely
Zoe grand Oh Mason grand amazing grand
amazed on excuse me Zoe I heard it on
sale the time it was the most fun name
to say she is phenomenal and watching
her act is just so great the the the
different levels of emotion that she
portrays through her eyes has just been
amazing what has it been like for you
finding that on-screen connection with
her as your own daughter
oh man she she's I think she's a lifer I
do think she's a life from when I say
lifer I mean somebody who will be in
this industry for many many years to
come
she has a gift she's incredibly talented
it's funny because she's so very
different from the character that she's
playing on screen and I find I always
find that fasting like how similar
someone is to the character versus you
know not and and so she she's also
that's been great we have another really
great question from Maddie and I love
this right now Maddie wants me to ask
you your opinions on some of the
Riverdale ships now you were a part of
ships when it was one tree hill or guilt
like relationship you just weren't
called ships then so and I
not sure if you I'm sure you've got a
crash course since being on Riverdale
but if a fan likes a certain couple
they'd be like I ship them so like
Peyton and Lucas they would have
combined their names together like yeah
I Shipley okay yeah so sorry guys this
one's a little bit it's all good I'm
here to break it down for you yeah I
know bug head yes what do you think of
bug head root for bug head yeah go bug
head I'm all about it we have Cheryl and
Tony Shoni oh man they're they're such a
right I love Joanie I got to be honest
they're energy they can they are the
Energizer Bunny duo of a lifetime
yeah and that's on screen off screen
it's incredible we have phallus which is
FP and Alice yeah it sounds a little
weird that's not a good name guys we got
fun in there not a good name but they
are a good couple and those fans so
desperately want them to be together but
Edgar is kind of putting a little bit of
a wedge in between them
sorry Effie you know you're my boy I
love ya but put a little little paws on
a phallus for a minute and then I'm
curious to know what do you think about
Archie's love life he's currently dating
Josie but you know fans always want him
with Veronica yeah there was a great
Tupac song I get around yeah been there
been there KJ Luke did that for a while
Benny I get it man I get it you know
Archie's uh somebody's got to do it yeah
it's hard work might as well well Chad I
really appreciate you joining me today
and for all you Riverdale fans who are
watching right now thank you so much for
watching I'm actually gonna keep
interviewing Chad to save some exclusive
Nuggets for you guys for future episodes
plus we're gonna play a fun game which
you are going to love I'll be releasing
it next week it's called never have I
ever
with Edgar ever never Oh get excited can
you say that five times fast no Chad
thank you so much for joining us thank
you River babies we'll see you soon bye
[Music]